So what do we have here?
we have
x sub 1 is
normally distributed at 3
for the mean and 0.4. It's standard deviation
and the other one 3.4 at the mean 0.2 and
standard deviation. And now we want to know which one is better. The one that has a better
mean or the one that has a better standard deviation.
Okay.
Okay now.
to standardize a random variable
you use
the random variable so you actually put it into a fraction.
So
That's so for example. You would take x sub 1.
subtract and then in the numerator use subtracted
from the population mean
divided by
the standard deviation
okay this
has the effect of shifting
the random variable
the mean of the random variable two the center
and when you do that, we usually use the letter z
to indicate that you have now.
Standardize your normal variable.
That you've shifted its meaning you have shifted the whole
thing.
to the left
and you will use Z sub 1 to indicate that this is
the
standardized random variable for the first
machine
and then of course you would do the same thing for the second one.
So let's add another one.
And this would simply become.
Z2
for x sub 2
okay. Now we vote now we have
two
random variables that have been standardized
now we can use this in combination with
the given
the measurements
to determine finally which one is
Which one's a better machine?